40 miles east of los angeles in the
foothills of the san gabriel mountains
is a pipe its job is to funnel water
from this dam
into this channel which borders los
angeles county
this pipe might look like any other
scattered across the west
but in the world of skateboarding
[Music]
it's a mecca
one time my dad drove my friend and i
there but we didn't really know where
we're going we finally came to a spot
that looked like it was probably
connected to mount baldy
and we were told that we had to leave if
you don't know that's tony hawk one of
the greatest skaters of all time
this year he finally made it to the
baldy pipe
it's a mission you gotta hike around you
gotta try to dodge
anyone you see that might try to kick
you out because there's plenty of
patrols there and then there's this
legendary gap
there's sort of right of passage you
have to jump over it if you're going to
be a true
baldy participant i jumped the gap for
the record
the baldy pipe is one of hundreds if not
thousands of legendary skate spots
around the world
that are hidden in plain sight this is
the story of how places
like this became this
it's america's newest sport and it's
called
skateboarding in 1965 skateboarding was
a full-blown fad
fad raced from west coast to east and
soon there was skateboarding in central
park
the first big wave of skateboarding is
as a surf related activity
in california but also in florida also
in australia
there's a great similarity between the
sport of skateboarding in the sport of
surfing
and it's basically people pretending
that they're on the ocean wave
ian borden is an architectural historian
and author of this incredible deep dive
into skateboarding history the big
milestone is probably the introduction
of polyurethane wheels to skateboarding
in the early 1970s
in the 1960s skateboard wheels were
typically made from metal or
clay which limited the breadth of
maneuvers skateboarders could do
the grip provided by polyurethane wheels
revitalized the sport
and opened it up to more adventurous
terrain by the mid-1970s
skateboarders were constantly on the
lookout for bigger wave-like structures
and empty pools drainage ditches and
gigantic pipes
quickly became skateboarding's most
coveted spots
the moment you find bits of architecture
that look
a bit like an ocean wave the
architecture changes that bit of asphalt
is no longer a bit of asphalt and
skaters start to do things that you you
you couldn't do on a surfboard they do
no handy there's they do invert
they do rock and rolls so there's a
cultural shift there as
well los angeles skaters found a small
reservoir in the hollywood hills
they called the viper bowl and wallows a
ditch that cut through a neighborhood on
the island of oahu in hawaii
it was pretty notorious because a lot of
the
70s skaters wrote it when they went to
hawaii or hawaiian skaters were riding
it
and it's this drainage ditch that just
keeps going down different shelves
there's no drainage just really like
that
paved schoolyards situated in the los
angeles hillsides
became a proving ground for young
skaters too the banks at kentur canyon
elementary
right here were frequented by skaters
since the 1960s and by the 1970s it was
one of the most widely seen backdrops
for skate photographs and videos
one of the things the skaters found is
that in various places
particularly out in the arizona desert
they'd find these great big
full pipes most of these pipes were from
the central arizona project a massive
water management initiative that began
construction
in 1973. for skateboarders
it was paradise and then there was the
baldy pipe
which skaters first discovered in 1969
images of skateboarders riding its
15-foot cavernous walls
turned this pipe into a skateboarding
landmark
it wasn't just photos the baldy pipe was
also featured in skate films which were
rising in popularity
just to get there you have to cross a
20-foot deep pit on an old log
so video becomes very important in this
it's how something exists in
history as told in video around 1976
investors saw a huge opportunity to
build parks that mimicked the
ever-growing list of sought-after skate
spots
and they started building them around
california the country
and the world this may seem an odd place
to be
the middle of an empty swimming pool but
this isn't just your ordinary everyday
swimming pool
this is the infamous dog pool a
skateboarder's paradise located in
marina del rey california
skatopia one of the most popular parks
in california
is big business there were full pipes
and pools
and winding concrete slalom courses that
mimicked drainage ditches
but it wasn't perfect soon after these
huge skate parks were built
the insurance needed to run them
skyrocketed
[Music]
and then skateboarding crashes
after skatepark numbers dwindled
skateboarders were kind of back to
square one
in the 80s it's mainly much more
a fewer number of die hard skaters
they continue to discover more and more
empty pools like this one
in the middle of the california desert
it used to be an old nudist camp
that was the pool that they they had and
somehow whenever the
i guess the news camp went bust i don't
know how to say it
the pool was skateable and some people
found it
it was discovered around 1982 and was
rightly dubbed the nude bowl
in the arizona desert another incredible
location was added to the list
the love bowl it was actually two giant
white backdrops from an abandoned tv
studio
but skateboarders also did something
else people started to build
their own ramps they started to build
ramps with walls that emulated pools but
but with flat
sections and that became the hot fight
1987's the search for animal chin
is a skate film that illustrates the
natural progression from ditches and
pools to half pipes
in the opening scene the skateboarders
take on wallows that hawaiian drainage
ditch
yes that's a young tony hawk and on one
of the very last scenes
i hung up going down one of the shelves
and basically sprawled onto the flat
and got chewed up on my elbow and i got
a staph infection
so the rest of my hawaiian vacation was
spent in a hotel on antibiotics
later on in the film they end up at a
motel pool in southern california
uh do you have a pool yeah we have a
pool but
you know it hasn't been filled in within
two years
um do you mind if we check it out
but in the final scene they discover
this ridiculously large wooden half pipe
in the middle of nowhere
the half pipe was especially made for
the film but a replica today exists at a
skate facility north of la
wheels of fire is another skate film
from the late 80s
and it featured both the nude bowl and
the love bowl but the most lasting
scenes of this video were of not as
calpis a pioneer of street skating
transforming his neighborhood into a
skate park
all of the footage of natas in that
video
was groundbreaking people thought wow
you can skate curbs like that you can
skate benches you can skate
fire hydrants like the whole world is a
skatepark now
so suddenly you didn't need to be in
california or in the arizona desert or
in
you know or in florida anymore you could
be anywhere
which brings us to this fire hydrant in
venice california
in 1989 natas kalpas did a 720 degree
spin on it
and it's just a perfect scenario too
because there's a pole next to it so he
kind of can
push off and start himself spinning and
also brace himself as he comes off
that doesn't make it any easier the move
became so iconic the trick is now called
the not a spin
[Music]
if you look at skateboard magazine
covers from the 60s through the 90s
one thing will quickly become clear
skateboarding's biggest spots went from
pools and pipes
to street spots namely giant stair sets
and ledges
and there's one plaza that was the
center of it all the embarcadero in san
francisco
it was a famous skate spot because of
all the other surroundings there was all
these ledges
different features that you could skate
around that was the hub of skating in
san francisco
and there was one specific spot that
became notorious because another
pioneering street
skater mark gonzalez ollied it it's no
longer there but here it is captured in
a thrasher magazine feature called spot
check
the gap itself was something that you
wouldn't have seen
necessarily as a challenge you know i
think a lot of people that came there
never even
realized the potential until guns got
there and jumped it
this footage shows how big the gap was
and the only way to cross it
was getting a massive amount of speed
launching into the air
and somehow keeping the skateboard right
under your feet
rightfully this spot was dubbed the gons
gap and became a hub for serious skaters
it's both a place and a moment and a
skater it's when the gons did a
particular move
yeah you don't mess around with the don
scout
[Music]
if there's one thing that hasn't changed
in the 60 years of skateboarding
it's that school campuses often have the
best skate spots
in video days 1991's milestones gate
film directed by a young spike jones
mark gonzalez grinds a bench at kendrick
canyon elementary
and in another scene ollie's a short but
incredibly deep set of four ledges at
wallenberg high school
in san francisco over the years skaters
have proved their worth by landing more
and more complicated tricks at
wallenberg
another notorious school spot is the
hollywood high 16 stair
which is the most geo-tagged location on
campus
and then there's el toro a 20 stair set
that has tormented skaters since
transworld skateboarding published this
image of heath kerchart board sliding
the center rail
the rail no longer exists but that
hasn't stopped anyone from hurling
themselves down the empty stairs
[Music]
but perhaps the most iconic location is
one that's no longer there the carlsbad
gap
it's a parking lot now but scroll back a
few years on google earth
and you'll see it there is a set of
stairs
that goes from one level to another at
the schoolyard and then next to it was a
patch of grass
and the grass went down at the same
angle as the stairs for the most part
but was actually a little bit less steep
and then there was just a wall
drop off at the end if you're jumping
the gap
you have to clear this higher part that
means you have to go much faster
and go actually much further if you
could do a trick down the stairs that's
one thing if you do a trick over the gap
that's a totally different thing
i've watched in re-watch skaters attempt
to land tricks at these spots over
and over and over and i realize that the
truly exhilarating moments happen only
after the skateboarder has failed a
hundred times
when chris called it a 360 flip at
wallenberg that was incredibly
impressive
but the footage that became even more
iconic is a compilation of him crashing
again and again so when somebody
in a video part you see them you know
failing something
five times ten times fifteen times
twenty times and then
finally getting it what matters is as
much
all the failed attempts as the final
thing
one of the biggest moments in
skateboarding history
was a fail it happened when jamie thomas
broke his board trying to land an
18-foot drop at a high school in
southern california
he didn't land it but the spot earned
the name the leap of faith
it's places where people have invested
blood sweat and tears
literally people can get extremely
impassioned about them
and feel a sense of loss when they go
and i think what skateboarding has
always been good at is
it tests our idea of what we want public
space to be
whether it's at the south banks in
london the ledges at the museum of
contemporary art in barcelona
the worst hour benches in berlin or a
25-foot stair set
in lyon skateboarders i think are a
constant reminder
that our cities can be creative and rich
[Music]
[Applause]
places
you